nous enchaînons les auditions depuis des
mois et des mois enfin sincèrement et et
sans comprendre finalement pourquoi
aujourd'hui les mesures qui sont prises
en fait oublie complètement
les personnes les plus pauvres on va
dire d'une façon dans la durée
structurelles et il est clair que
les personnes engagées au sein du
mouvement atd quart monde puisque ce
sont des personnes qui font le choix de
s'engager ou c1 du mouvement et pour
lutter contre la pauvreté et est
toujours allé chercher les personnes qui
manquent encore et donc les personnes
avec qui nous cheminons ce sont des
personnes qui vivent dans l'extrême
pauvreté donc
au niveau des revenus médians en fait ça
se situe au niveau de 40% du revenu
médian soit avec à peu près 6 194 euros
par mois et en france on rappelle
toujours ce chiffre là certainement vous
l'avez entendu avec nos prédécesseurs au
niveau de l'adresse et c est ça concerne
deux ça concerne deux millions deux cent
mille personnes qui vivent avec ce ces
ressources ou avec moins que ses
ressources voilà donc on est on est
toujours très entre eux toujours très
important de situer sa 2 millions de
personnes c'est énorme et aujourd'hui on
fait le constat évidemment que les
personnes très pauvres sont sont ou ont
dû oublier puisque les mesures ne sont
pas structurel les mesures qui ont été
apportées sont de nature à
apporter
quelques voilà quand on donne 150 euros
à une famille pendant la période dans
laquelle on traverse ça ne peut être
qu'un pansement donc c'est pour nous
c'est toujours très difficile
aujourd'hui
d'imaginer
est ce qu'on les oublie pas quoi voilà
donc voila et donc les différents
chiffres vous les avez avec les
différents organismes qui sont qui sont
en charge de ces questions dont le ps
qui a disparu d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui mais voilà
donc ce dont je vais vous parler c'est
vraiment d hermann d'éléments qui sont
partagés dans des lieux de prise de
parole et d'élaboration de la pensée que
notre mouvement en fait développe depuis
60 ans un qui sont par exemple les
universités populaires car monde où tous
les groupes
dans lesquels les personnes travaillent
réfléchisse et cesse d'apporter des
solutions à partir de leur expérience de
vie et elles ont souvent des solutions à
apporter voilà et qu'est ce qu'on en
apprend du coup de tout ça
la période fait qu'on est vraiment au
coeur d'une urgence où chacun et chacune
des personnes qui vivent dans ces
situations de vie très difficiles ont
été amenés à agir elles ont été amenées
à agir tout d'abord concernant enfin
pour les personnes qui ont des enfants
scolarisés à domicile quand il a fallu
se battre pour effectivement
être à la hauteur pour que les enfants
suivent et poursuivre à la rentrée
ensuite et ça ça a été un vrai combat
autour de cette question d'être équipé
d'une de numérique être connecté être
formés et là on s'est rendu compte
effectivement du fossé et de l'écart de
les cards avec ce que vivent toutes ces
personnes qui n'ont pas pu
sans se faire aider en tout cas qui
n'ont pas pu assurer cette scolarisation
dans un premier temps mais évidemment
après les choses se sont mises en route
grâce à l'aide qui a pu être apportée
voilà cette période oblige les gens
aussi à quinon qui ont très très peu de
ressources à se battre pour se nourrir
coûte que coûte
et pour faire face aussi à l'endettement
à l'endettement qui a été très important
pour faire face aux charges de logement
notamment
beaucoup de personnes ont perdu les
activités parallèles qu'elle pouvait
avoir pour survivre et ne pas faire
justement appel à l'aide alimentaire
habituellement
ce qui est vraiment voilà
toutes ces questions-là liés à la
pandémie à la façon dont les personnes
l'impact que la pandémie a et que la
période de confinement à
a des impacts très très fort sur les
personnes qui sont dans des situations
de vie très difficiles
donc on voulait vraiment rappeler tout
le courage que ces personnes ont pour
subvenir aux besoins des enfants et
essayez donc à tout prix que les enfants
soient pas pénalisés par manque
d'équipements ou par manque d'argent
pour les nourrir voilà une maman
militante quart monde donc une maman qui
qui est engagée dans notre mouvement
nous partager pendant le confinement
elle disait d'abord je me bats et je
fais manger les enfants la suite c'est
après et en ce moment une seule chose
compte c'est de manger
rappelait déjà là dans quoi sont dans
quelles urgences sont effectivement les
gens voient là parce que la grande
pauvreté effectivement elle est faite
d'insécurité permanente elle empêche de
se projeter d'assumer ses
responsabilités notamment vis-à-vis de
sa famille et notamment
une des premières insécurité conques ont
pointé conre points toujours et toujours
c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec un revenu
minimum qui est le rsa on ne peut pas
vivre et les gens leur disent nous
sommes en train de mener un travail avec
la cour des comptes qui qui nous a
demandé de rejoindre un comité
d'accompagnement sur l'évaluation du rsa
donc ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on
travaille vraiment avec des personnes
qui sont engagés dans le mouvement et
qui habite dans différents régions
france et c'est ce qu'elle re 10 et
elles leur disent très fort on ne peut
pas vivre avec un rsa on ne peut pas
assumer de vivre et de se loger etc
voilà donc c'est on se demandait
vraiment à quel moment les mesures
prises donc pendant cette période permet
de vraiment aux personnes d'accéder à
des droits et pas seulement de combler
des manques à quel moment
on se pose la question de comment les
personnes devraient pouvoir faire face
par semaine leurs responsabilités sans
vivre la honte et l'humiliation de
devoir faire appel à l'aide du mal à
l'aide alimentaire pour se nourrir il
faut bien comprendre que le combat est
quotidien pour résister pour survivre et
c'est une constante vraiment dans la vie
des plus pauvres
on se rend compte par ailleurs que
effectivement les choix qui sont faits
c'est d'institutionnaliser l'aide
alimentaire par exemple voilà même si on
voit bien que les personnes ont
absolument besoin de soutien pour nous
le la réponse ne peut être que
structurel et sur du long terme et non
pas par des mesures qui vont qui vont
des mesures pansements voilà pour pour
être assez rapide
voilà donc les signes les signes
d'aggravation
les signes d'aggravation de delà de la
pauvreté se sont vraiment toujours des
difficultés qui se sont amplifiés pour
l'accès au logement
par exemple accéder à un logement donc
on refera pas le rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre est sorti il ya très peu de
jours
des millions de personnes sont mal
logées et accéder aujourd'hui à un
logement quand on a quand on a très peu
de ressources est quasi impossible on
l'a aussi démontré à plusieurs reprises
voilà donc
accéder à un logement très social ou en
tout cas assez d un logement avec des
loyers qu'ils puissent être accessibles
c'était vraiment un défi un défi
aujourd'hui en france au-delà du fait
qu'ils aient pas assez de logements
évidemment voilà
les inégalités donc s'accroissent et 1d
des populations les plus impactés qui
chemine avec nous donc ils sont engagés
au sein du mois atd quart monde on sent
vraiment que les plus impactés sont les
jeunes
pour qui le combat doit devrait être de
leur donner toutes les chances de se
former et de trouver un emploi voilà
donc effectivement l'observatoire des
inégalités fait park 1 1 jeune sur dix
est aujourd'hui en situation de pauvreté
donc un jeune c'est à dire entre 18 et
29 ans
voilà il s'agit essentiellement de
jeunes qui sont donc peu diplômés en
recherche d'emploi
mais la baisse d'activité économique et
à la crise sanitaire les touchent
vraiment de plein fouet et ce phénomène
existait bien sûr avant la crise et la
crise n'a fait qu'aggraver tout cela
ce qui est intéressant c'est que l'état
au départ dans la stratégie lutte contre
la pauvreté en 2018 quand elle a été
présentée l'état l'état avait fait part
donc d'une mesure qui paraît qui
paraissait ou qui paraît très
intéressante qui est de garantir l'état
doit garantir la formation et
l'accompagnement pour tous les jeunes de
16 à 18 ans
et effectivement le constat qui est fait
de deux ans un peu plus de deux ans
après quand on interroge les missions
locales ou en tout cas les gens avec qui
nous sommes en lien notamment émissions
locales on s'aperçoit qu'en fait
par exemple les missions locales en tout
cas quand on veut vraiment un fléchage
et de un budget qui a été allouée et
certaines missions locales en fonction
du nombre de jeunes accompagnés ont reçu
plus ou moins est ce qu'on nous dit
c'est que
les comment les professionnels en fait
ne sont pas nous ont ce qu'on cherche
c'est des professionnels qu'ils aillent
vers qui qui se rendent vers les jeunes
qui sont vraiment invisible et qui sont
qui sont pas suivies qui sont pas
accompagnés qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
connues et qu'on décroché de l'école ou
que l'école a décroché du système
scolaire et s'avère qu'en fait les
missions locales ont pas de par exemple
de professionnels d'éducateurs
spécialisés etc qui ont qui ont 7 cette
formation pour de connaissance des
familles et de la proche des familles et
c est donc pour nous tant que des
mesures ne seront pas on ne comprendra
pas ce qui ce qui doit permettre d'aller
vers ces jeunes et d'aller les
rencontrer de prendre ce temps d'aller
au rythme des jeunes qui sont les plus
impactées et donc les plus éloignés de
tout qui n'ont pas de formation qui sont
partis qui sont sortis de l'école très
tôt
il est clair que tant que les moyens de
ce conte pas mis vers eux on aura
toujours un pan de la population qui est
totalement oubliée je parle vraiment des
personnes qu'ils sont totalement oubliés
donc on parlait de deux millions de
personnes c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
un petit nombre quoi voilà
donc voilà on se dit que c'est essentiel
de pouvoir repenser
les politiques publiques à partir de
ceux qui sont les plus oubliés pour ça
puisse bénéficier à tous en fête voilà
donc
ce qu'on
vous avait aussi envie de dire peut-être
pour terminer enfin toutes les toutes
les
les autres difficultés fin majeur qu'on
a on a on a recensé c'est évidemment
toutes les questions d'accès aux soins
et les renoncements aux soins voilà pour
aller directement au but c'est ce et les
renoncements aux soins et la période
fait que les personnes beaucoup de
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes
renoncent aux soins ou n'ont plus
d'accès au droit en fait un droit de
base
des grandes grandes difficultés par
rapport à ça voilà
voilà
que vous vous posez aussi la question de
comment prévenir le basculement des
personnes dans la pauvreté et comment
les personnes on pourrait effectivement
permettre aux personnes de d'en sortir
donc forcément faire quelque chose qu'on
répète et qu'on est très nombreux au
niveau des associations a répété
ensemble
la première chose ce serait de faire un
vrai choix politique
effectivement d'augmenter le rsa rien
rien ne dit
que rien ne prouve en fait aucun élément
ne prouve aujourd'hui que d'augmenter le
rsa ça d un site très les personnes à
travailler voilà donc le travail qu'on
mène pour la cour des comptes l'a au
niveau de l'évaluation du rsa dans
toutes les personnes qu'on a interrogé
les travaux qu'on a menées montrent bien
que les personnes veulent une activité
se veulent être utiles et veulent être
reconnus par rapport à ce qu'ils savent
faire par rapport aux compétences et
comment on peut réfléchir avec eux à
tout ça je reviendrais pas sur
l'expérimentation territoire à zéro
chômeur mais on a on prouve je veux dire
on prouve très clairement que c'est
possible quand on a une solidarité
territoire et quand on repense à partir
des plus pauvres à partir des gens qui
sont plus élevés qui sont là en
l'occurrence chômeurs de longue durée on
prouve que les choses sont possibles
mais
mettons nous ensemble et mettons nous
ensemble avec les personnes sans elle
rien ne pourra être imaginer où les
politiques publiques seront toujours en
fête ou à côté où on risque de deuil
en font c'est encore un peu plus les
personnes quand on quand on est à côté
quoi voilà donc c'est un revenu minimum
que nous on estime comme avec les autres
associations à minima à 850 euros
pour pouvoir un minima de vivre seul ou
à se vivre dignement se loger manger se
vêtir et peut-être avoir des loisirs
c'est à dire que pour nous la culture
est tellement essentiel que pour nous ça
fait absolument partie en fait des
besoins de base voilà
les trois autres points rapidement c'est
pour prévenir le basculement et
permettent aux gens de s'en sortir c'est
d'avoir un logement décent et de pouvoir
vivre dans un logement décent avec un
espace de vie pour chacun on l'a vu lors
du premier confinement les gens impact
et c'était des personnes qui avaient
vraiment des conditions de logement
exigu particulièrement extrêmes et et
qui ont très très mal vécu évidemment ça
réseau rénové les habitats insalubres
évidemment et d'exiger aussi que la loi
sru soit respectée
ça paraît tellement essentiel en fait de
pouvoir construire de logements
à partir des voilà de cette loi sru
avoir un emploi digne on en a parlé
rapidement mais les personnes souffrent
de ne pas avoir d'emploi digne et de ne
pas avoir non plus de propositions de
formations comme les les jeunes le
demande ou en tout cas permettre aux
jeunes qui souhaitent de faire des
formations choisies pour des métiers
choisis et puis ensuite la troisième
chose c'était effectivement autour des
services publics d'éducation de santé et
d'assurance chômage et de retraite de
qualité et accessibles à chacun parce
que voilà toujours les premiers perdent
les premiers pénalisés lorsque les
services publics dysfonctionne sont
toujours les plus pauvres voilà et donc
pour finir
la question de la participation des
personnes très pauvres
dans l'élaboration des politiques
publiques dans l'évaluation des
politiques publiques et on voit que la
cour des comptes a fait la démarche là
de nous associer on est deux
associations à être associé à au comité
d'accompagnement on voit bien que
voilà quand la démarche est faite et
qu'on réfléchisse ensemble et qu'on
évalue les choses on verra ce que ça
donne évidemment mais à partir de
l'expérience de vie des personnes seules
ces personnes là peuvent dire évaluer
d'une façon précise en fait les
conséquences les impacts sur leur vie et
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait changer
évidemment avec des solutions et les
préconisations
voilà j'en ai terminé
à bout pour cette année je veux passer
la parole à monsieur thierry vers le roi
donc qui représente la croix rouge
française
bonjour
microsemi
m'a tout d'abord merci de nous donner de
nous donner la parole j'ai tête vous
préciser d'où je parle parce que je
trouve que c'est toujours important pour
un parent de préciser que j'appartiens
la direction des métiers des opérations
dont plutôt la branche qui est mobilisé
sur les établissements dans la croix
rouge française et gestionnaires et au
delà des délégués nationale lutte contre
les exclusions je suis aussi délégué
national sur nos dispositifs enfants et
familles est probablement en tout cas
sur les questions que vous aurez à poser
des fois je m'appuie aussi en tout cas
sur ce que nous voient enfin en tout cas
nos établissements peuvent proposer
aussi sûr c'est sur ces aspects là j'ai
bien sûr essayer de prendre le temps
avec mes collègues de croiser des
informations mais c'est pour vous dire
parfois si des fois je suis un peu en
difficulté pour répondre je me
permettrai de retourner vers mes
collègues vous demandiez en premier lieu
je pense des évolutions vous nous
indiquez que vous aviez des
statisticiens avant nous donc je ne vais
pas rentrer trop peut-être moi je
voulais insister sur sur un point je
pense qu'ils ont dû vous vous amener un
depuis des années nous étions plutôt sur
un sur un plateau en tout cas au niveau
au niveau du seuil de pauvreté nous
espérions tous que un jour ce seul et
les descendre et qu'effectivement en
tout cas aujourd'hui les perspectives
ont été sérieusement sérieusement
bousculés on y reviendra par la suite
néanmoins je tenais à attirer votre à
votre attention sur le fait qu' on a
observé une intensification de la grande
pauvreté et qu'il faut aussi être
particulièrement attentifs à l'ensemble
de ces éléments
autre outil qui a d'ailleurs été cité
aussi par mam collègues je pense qu'elle
sait la stratégie de lutte contre la
pauvreté qui nous a quand même année en
tout cas on va dire un un diagnostic
parfois un diagnostic quelque peu
je suis fière effrayant puisqu'il
rappeler quand même qu'il fallait six
générations pour pouvoir sortir de la
pauvreté je pense que nous sommes nous
avons tous été à nous amener à nous
interroger effectivement sur ce
qu'aujourd'hui notre république pouvait
justement pouvait justement proposé peut
être d'attirer
votre attention pour ma part j'avais
noté 3 public c'est toujours délicat de
faire ce découpage mais ça facilite
l'expliquent les explications je pense
qu'on a quand même la question
aujourd'hui des jeunes qui sont avec des
mesures de protection
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance et en
particulier comment ils sortent de ce
dispositif et comment aussi aujourd'hui
nous rencontrons
un certain nombre de personnes à la rue
qui ont eu des passages par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance donc quand même
comment on peut mieux travailler avec ce
public c'était une des propositions dans
le cadre de la stratégie de lutte contre
la pauvreté mais je devrai avouer que
c'est assez décevant en tout cas sur les
résultats que nous a pu vont pu
complètement obtenir au delà du fait que
l'état d'urgence interdit normalement au
département de faire sortir les jeunes à
leur majorité
la question aussi de l'un de
l'intensification de du statut de
monoparentalité qui forcément a quand
même aujourd'hui un impact sur la
question des ressources lorsqu'on parle
de précarité financière
et puis aussi la question
des migrations et de comment nous
accueillons aujourd'hui les personnes en
les personnes en parcours d'exil
peut-être puisque vous nous interroger
sur les neuf nouvelles formes de
précarité
je voulais comme atd quart monde a pu le
faire insisté quand même sur un constat
assez dramatique du premier confinement
nous avons pu observer si on peut le
formuler de cette façon là qu'une qu'un
certain nombre de familles n'étaient pas
en capacité simplement de nourrir leur
famille une fois que la cantine ne
fonctionnait plus une fois qu'un certain
nombre de dispositifs
ne fonctionnait plus et ça vient donc de
fait interrogé
ce ce point d'achoppement
particulier auquel aujourd'hui
s'ajoutent je ne le fais pas mais les
files d'attentes des études des
étudiants
dans les dispositifs d aide alimentaire
qui nous amène quand même à constater
aujourd'hui que dans ce pays un certain
nombre de français enfin et souffrent de
la faim ce qui bien sûr de nos années
tous à nous interroger
le premier confinement il a rappelé
aussi combien les personnes qui étaient
en grande précarité est en situation de
pauvreté probablement aussi par rapport
à des conditions de logement qui ont été
rappelés se trouvent aussi en difficulté
pour pouvoir conduire
sereinement l'éducation de leurs enfants
dans un système scolaire quelque peu
bouleversé et dans des environnements
eux aussi
bousculer même si effectivement on a vu
que le deuxième confinement est
aujourd'hui ont permis d'organiser les
choses autrement on peut quand même
observé qu' il ya eu d impact
assez fort je me permets de rappeler
aussi que
en tout cas la crise sanitaire ou cette
période d'urgence fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'état mobilise 200 mille places
d'hébergement d'urgence qui montre là
aussi que cela fait un nombre de
personnes importantes qui se retrouvent
sans en tout cas sans un logement qui
leur permet en tout cas d'évoluer avec
une certaine forme de sérénité
je ne sais pas si je dois développer je
pense qu'on ne reviendra peut-être dans
les questions la situation actuelle de
la jeunesse ou des jeunes est ce parce
que je pense que l'on va croiser
qu'elles sont impactés les unes les
autres selon les difficultés qu'elles
rencontrent
je voudrais vous apporter aussi un point
de ne pas tout cas d'essayer d'avoir une
attention sur la situation en outre-mer
où là aussi on observe des situations
particulièrement tendue et le
confinement en tout cas pour la croix
rouge française a été pour nous
l'occasion d'observer plus grandement la
question où l'impact de l'isolément sur
les situations de précarité
on a mis en place vous le savez
peut-être dans le cadre du premier
confinement un numéro d'appel qui
s'appelle croix rouge c'est vous qui
permettait aussi de permettre d'avoir
accès en tout cas à ce qu'on puisse vous
faire vos courses pouvoir vous amener
chez vous pour les personnes isolées
vaudé vos médicaments ou âme ou à manger
dans le cadre du premier confinement
c'est quand même un tiers
du coût des appels des déplacements que
nous avons faits qui ont été faits entre
en tout cas où ces paniers ont été
gratuits puisque les personnes n'étaient
pas en capacité de pouvoir de pouvoir se
payer
à manger cette question de l' isolement
elle rappelle aussi notre précarité
devant la santé psychologique et combien
aussi les plus fragiles
tu es un lourd tribut j'ai viendrait
peut-être sur les questions de 2,2 de
prévention
sur l'aggravation de la crise moi je
vous ai relevé en tout cas un chiffre
sur nos marotte donc là qui est un
chiffre de la croix rouge française
en marotte ses 86 % de personnes qui ont
été rencontrés en plus
alors que on devait en tout cas limités
comme je vous le rappeler en tout cas
que le nombre de personnes mis en
hébergement d'urgence a été augmentée
c'est en volume de personnes 22 mille
personnes qui ont été rencontrés dont
chiffre qui me glace à chaque fois que
je le prononce dont 6000 enfants ce qui
représente quand même 25 % des personnes
que nous rencontrons
à la rue dans un pays qui se revendique
comme étant un pays développé
ça a posé aussi la question justement de
la santé et de comment en tout cas on
évolue pour pouvoir aussi apporter la
santé aux personnes
les plus précaires je pense en
particulier au développement des équipes
mobiles
dans
vos questions sur comment prévenir je
pense qu'il ya un point d'intervention
qui aussi a rappelé sur l'invisibilité
des populations qui n'ont pas recours à
nos dispositifs et c'est pour ça que moi
même j'ai insisterait comme cela a été
fait sur le fait de développer les
dispositifs qui vont vers ces personnes
mais aussi qui permettent de développer
du dialogue avec des personnes et de
lever les poings de difficultés puisque
souvent si elles n'ont plus recours est
à la fois
des fois aussi une forme d'usure après
des combats perpétuelle pour pouvoir
obtenir à obtenir leurs droits et aussi
une méconnaissance je pense que ça nous
rappelle justement la tension est
l'importance de pouvoir être accompagné
lorsqu on le souhaite et aussi d'avoir
cette vigilance aujourd'hui sur les
mouvements de déprime de dépression de
comme nous voudrons à le qualifier mais
deux sont actifs
si m'appartient pas de définir quel est
le revenu décent il faut quand même nous
interroger aujourd'hui comment on se
doit de solvabiliser les personnes et il
sera difficile aujourd'hui de travail en
prévention si on ne permet pas aux
personnes d'avoir les ressources
financières qui leur permettent de vivre
de les vivre décemment et ça a été aussi
indiqué je voulais assister aujourd'hui
sur les dispositifs nécessaires à mettre
pour lutter ce qu'on appelle j'allais
dire assez pompeusement contre la
fracture numérique
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'aujourd'hui faire des démarches sans
avoir accès au numérique est très
complet et très complexe et cette lutte
contre la fracture numérique est
vraiment très diverses puisque
effectivement l'axé j'allais dire à
l'outil est à voir en tout cas un accès
internet mais c'est aussi pouvoir avoir
l'accès à la compréhension
nous on s'est aperçu aussi dans le
premier confinement qu'on pouvait avoir
des dispositifs ont en tout cas des
lieux où les personnes avaient accès à
ces outils informatiques mais néanmoins
elle n'était pas en capacité de pouvoir
les utiliser ce qui du coup ne servait
pas à grand chose
pour elle je ne sais pas si on y viendra
mais c'est pour moi un élément connext
de la crise je voudrais attirer aussi
votre attention sur la stratégie
vaccinale est le fait que les personnes
les plus précaires et les plus pauvres
ne soient ne soit pas oubliée dans le
cadre de cette stratégie mais on y
reviendra peut-être plus
particulièrement dans les questions si
vous en avez sur le sujet voilà merci
pour votre écoute en ce qui concerne
effectivement les enjeux de statistiques
alors vous l'avez dit monsieur verger
vous travaillez avec l'insee et la dares
et l'adresse sur un certain nombre de
deux groupes travaux est-ce que
néanmoins on peut se dire qu'entre la
réalité terrain et c'est bien ça l'enjeu
est de le rencontre un qui ont été
proposées par madame la présidente c'est
à dire à la fois avoir une vision pardon
du terme un peu de techno de ce que sont
les chiffres et puis à la fois une
vision terrain est ce que vous vous y
retrouver ou est-ce qu effectivement il
ya des divergences d'approché entre ce
que vous pouvez ressentir est ce que
vous pouvez trouver au niveau du terrain
ça c'est la première question la
deuxième question
qui qui était effectivement une approche
qui était une question a été posée à
part nos collègues comment réussir à
sortir de cet enjeu de pauvreté et de
grande pauvreté et la représentante de
l'insee annoncé le fait qu'il fallait
peut-être un peu marcher sur deux jambes
c'est à dire un un principe de
redistribution est un principe d'accès à
l'emploi est ce que vous partagez ces
deux jambes qui peuvent être
effectivement une capacité de sortir de
cet enjeu de grande pauvreté ou de
pauvreté
autre question relative
effectivement au rôle des associations
et des pouvoirs publics
je crois que c'est le représentant de la
drees qui disait que 1 deschamps qui
restait à couvrir qu'il n'était
peut-être pas suffisamment étudié était
le champ de l'aide alimentaire
dans notre société est ce qu'on a en la
matière un certain nombre d' approche
complémentaire à avoir est ce que vous
parliez madame bouyer d'une
technocratisation de l'aide alimentaire
ce que c'est pas une crainte que vous
pouvez avoir quand on évoque que ces
sujets là mais comment est ce que vous
voyez des choses est ce qu'on peut
j'allais dire avoir une approche un peu
plus pointue sur sur l'intégralité du
travail que vous faites en particulier
et puis peut-être sur les nouvelles
populations à vous allez vous avez
beaucoup parlé des jeunes alors je vous
dire aussi qu'à une autre mission
d'information au sénat qui traite des
jeunes alors peut-être qu'on n'ira pas
forcément et nécessairement ceci étant
il ya des dispositifs qui existent
aujourd'hui alors j'étais pas qu'ils
sont forcément bien en tout cas on a pu
les suivre un jeune une solution le
principe de apporté à l'afpa de pouvoir
suivre les jeunes de 16-18 en matière de
scolarisation et d'accès au milieu
professionnel est ce que vous en voyez
le retour terrain même si ce sont des
dispositifs qui sont assez récent est-ce
que cela vous semble être dispositifs
qui sont plutôt pertinent est ce que
vous avez sur ces indépendants une
vision un peu plus précise je crois que
c'est vous monsieur couvert le roi qui
avait parlé de des années pendant qu'ils
étaient plus présents à dents dans les
populations pouvaient rencontrer
qu'est-ce que quelques elle qu'est ce
que recouvre ce champ là et puis
peut-être aussi sur le rsa je me permets
monsieur berger parce que j'ai lu avec
attention le rapport du secours
catholique alors on est nombreux au
niveau du 2 des sénateurs a siégé à ses
équipes pluridisciplinaires qui à un
moment donné rencontre les allocataires
du rsa c'est vrai prennent un certain
nombre de décisions moi je voulais juste
pondérer si vous voulez ces approches
lac qui sont souvent d approche très
humaine je me permets de le dire même si
la sanction peut être un peu difficile
mais quand on parle du rsa et vous
l'avez tous évoqués vous êtes tous
favorables même si il y à des études en
cours à réaugmenter le seuil du rsa est
ce qu'en parallèle il y à des
discussions qui ont lieu sur le montant
du smic qui en règle générale est quand
même une donnée qui qui doit
éventuellement être à rapprocher du
montant du rsa en termes d'écarts vous
avez effectivement le dit que ce n'était
pas forcément un frein pour l'accès à
l'emploi mais c'est quand même donné
qu'il faut qu'on est en tête et par
ailleurs le rsa effectivement il ya un
certain nombre de contraintes qu'un
certain nombre de j'allais dire de
2,2 nécessité pour les allocataires de
remplir un certain nombre de conditions
est ce que pour autant si on les
supprime complètement est ce que c'est
bien ce que c'est pas bien j'aimerais
bien avoir votre sentiment sur sur ce
rsa même si je sais qu'il ya des travaux
en cours
qui répondent le super fait
oui je serai sûrement complété par mes
collègues je vien répondre à vos
différentes questions à d'abord des
différences entre la statistique et le
terrain c'est comme très complémentaires
et je trouve que c'est vraiment très
important que l'insee et de la drees
elle se travaille actuellement de
d'essayer de repérer les évolutions de
la pauvreté nous mêmes sommes aussi en
train de monter un
baromètre pour regarder les évolutions
avec nos équipes locales qui participent
à ce travail bas voire 150 équipes
locales mobilisés pour pointer les
évolutions opéré au niveau de leur
territoire chaque chaque trimestre de
façon à compléter l'analyse annuelle du
rapport était de la pauvreté
je dirai ce qui manque surtout dans les
statistiques officielles c'est que les
personnes
sans papiers ne sont pas présentes
ni un statut instable donc on a
effectivement tout cette catégorie
d'invisibles qui est quand même une
catégorie extrêmement pauvres y
extrêmement précaire et
c'est notamment un des apports d'un
rapport comme l'autre de l'est
visibiliser et c'est pour ce que c'est
pour ça qu'il est aussi une différence
qui peuvent être parfois conséquentes
alors après sur la redistribution et
l'accès à l'emploi vous avez raison il y
a deux il y a deux pieds je pense que ça
c'est un bon
c'est un bon point d' analyse de se dire
qu'il y assez de pied nous on incarne
par tout ce qui est autour de d'un
revenu minimum le plus garantie possible
j'y reviendrai mais toutes les
initiatives autour de territoires zéro
chômeur de longue durée par exemple
lancé par atd dans lequel nous sommes
aussi acteurs montre bien l'importance
d'avoir des propositions autour de
l'emploi c'est aussi tout l'enjeu de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
et aujourd'hui
vous savez qu'il y ait un petit peu de
deux idées qui sont qui sont en l'air
des noirs d'une part ce côté revenu de
base voire revenu universel
et puis là où le côté comment faire
vivre la garantie à l'emploi qui est
aussi dans l'engagement que l'on doit
avoir et que et colas la france 1-2 puis
depuis que 46 donc on a vraiment un un
enjeu là à le faire vivre et la
mobilisation des territoires est sans
doute le bon lieu pour le faire vivre
donc il faut pouvoir avancer sans doute
pas à pas du côté de l'expérience
territoire 0 chômeurs de longue durée en
tant que tel parce que vouloir aller
trop vite pourrait aussi fragiliser
l'expérimentation mais trouver des
moyens de faire vivre la garantie à
l'emploi dans le territoire avec des
acteurs qui s'engagent localement et qui
sent soutenu par l'état pour cela s'est
effectivement notre pied parce qu'on
peut pas demander aux personnes d'être
actif dans la recherche d'emploi ou dans
la formation s'il n'ya pas d'emplois
dans la région et la crise a plutôt
aggravé l'absence d'emploi mais en même
temps des besoins écologiques des
besoins de relation des besoins
d'accompagnement des personnes il y en a
énormément si on veut pouvoir
rénové 700 mille logements par an eh
bien on n'a pas assez d'artisans pour le
faire aujourd'hui donc des besoins il y
en a
mais encore faut-il qu'on puisse
accompagner ses créations d'emplois et
accompagner les personnes vers ses
créations d'emplois voilà donc voilà on
est tout à fait d'accord d'accompagner
cela en le faisant sur les territoires
et nous aussi en étant acteur dans cet
accompagnement des personnes puisque
c'est ça notre notre spécificité
sur l'aide alimentaire vous avez raison
c'est un enjeu extrêmement important ça
reste la deuxième demande des personnes
qui viennent au secours catholique alors
que pourtant nous faisons plutôt moins
d' aide alimentaire que qu'il ya
quelques décennies
et avec la crise nous avons mobilisé des
sommes assez conséquente pour proposer
des chèques services qui ont l'avantagé
d'être
pour les personnes une possibilité de
choisir elle même ce qu'elle achète avec
et c'est ça qui nous semblent
intéressants dedans dire que dans l'aide
alimentaire reçues on n'a souvent pas le
choix ou faiblement le choix ça aussi un
côté parfois très difficiles qu'elle
exprime un de devoir se mettre dans la
queue et et d'attendre d'être servi
le chèque service à davantage de pouvoir
aller dans un magasin et de pouvoir
acheter ce dont on a besoin
donc ça doit pouvoir se développer on a
eu des difficultés à ce que des magasins
acceptent ces chèques service au début
ça s'est progressivement résolu je pense
qu'il y a un travail que doit continuer
à se faire avec les les enseignes pour
que ce soit accepté sans aucune
réticence mais il ya sans doute quelque
chose à envisager et puis aussi de la
promotion disons de la solidarité
alimentaire de deux territoires c'est à
dire tout comme on peut organiser ces
circuits courts c'est ce fait d'avoir
des jardins partagés d'avoir de la
possibilité de de travailler sur aussi
de de l'alimentation que l'on fait
ensemble
des cuisines collectives toutes ces
initiatives là nous semble extrêmement
importante à être soutenus mais le chant
disons de l'axé dit à l'alimentation est
certainement un des chants les plus
importants à promouvoir et on peut faire
beaucoup plus et beaucoup mieux que la
simple aide alimentaire basique qui peut
être extrêmement durs à vivre en fait
pour les personnes
les jeunes on avait parlé donc
effectivement il ya vraiment besoin de
trouver des solutions par rapport aux
jeunes beaucoup de choses ont été
annoncées mais elles restent quand même
pour nous assez peu visible sur leur
impact aujourd'hui franchement et puis
on voit bien la difficulté même avec le
lead est plutôt séduisante de la
garantie jeunes universel qui est un
vrai progrès si elle se met en place
comme
comme proposé par le coche
ceci dit elle est un vrai progrès
notamment par son aspect droits ouverts
après ce qu'on réussira à pouvoir
permettre un accompagnement avec les
circuits actuels avec les missions
locales qui ont besoin d'être aidés et
renforcer considérablement si on veut
passer changer d'échelle parce que même
si on fait deux cent mille à deux cent
mille jeunes c'est une amélioration mais
on est très très loin du compte il faut
pouvoir accompagner aujourd'hui 700 à
900 mille jeunes si on veut pouvoir
avoir un impact décisif par rapport à
l'appauvrissement des jeunes donc voilà
il ya des choses qui sont plutôt
intéressante dans l'idée en tout cas et
ça permet de devenir aussi vers les
idées de rsa et de revenus minimaux
garantis
l'accompagnement est évidemment très
important les gens demandent à être
accompagnés
pendant d
les idiots que l'on a fait pour le
rapport quelqu'un disait mais
il avait rencontré son assistante
sociale qu'il disait mais où est-ce que
vous en êtes et liva vous m'avez laissé
ya un an
parce que depuis j'ai eu des difficultés
et finalement on n'a pas pu en
rediscuter
alors différentes raisons expliquer cela
mais revoilà
les gens sont très demandeurs d'un
accompagnement trailer très
majoritairement vers évidemment des
situations différentes et diversifiée
mais très majoritairement ils sont
demandeurs d'un accompagnement et d'un
accompagnement de qualité humains
positif mais c'est là où on voit que
tout la menace de la sanction est
fondamentalement quelque chose qui est
contre-productif car elle met cette
espèce de damoclès où ils devraient
avoir du lien et de
et de l'accompagnement positif du
renforcement
alors on l'a bien pris en compte en
matière d'éducation mais pas encore en
matière sociale
donc peut-être que c'est la nouvelle
révolution qu'il faut faire avancer en
tout cas je pense que les gens le mérite
et et dans leurs rêves les personnes
souhaitent avoir accès à un emploi
souhaité être socialement économiquement
reconnus dans leurs activités qu'elles
font ou qu'elle aimerait faire donc
c'est toujours des applaudissements dans
un groupe quand quelqu'un a trouvé un
travail
donc encore une fois l'enjeu n'est pas
de penser que certains s'en
contenteraient peut-être parfois un
petit moment parce que leur le ressort
est cassé ou parce qu'il ya d'autres
enjeux sociaux ou de santé à régler
d'abord mais fondamentalement les gens
veulent être actifs dans la société et
être reconnu pour cela
quitte à être dans des situations de
précarité
mais qui peuvent être quand même pour
eux une vraie avancée et c'est là tout
l'enjeu des indépendants les
indépendants sont justement des parce
que les indépendances est quand même
largement des des auto entrepreneurs
s'est largement des personnes qui sont
des livreurs ou ou des personnes qui
font juste quelques heures
mais qui ont trouvé là une voie
la grande difficulté c'est l'absence de
protection sociale de ses métiers et
l'absence de reconnaissance du lien
d'employeurs mais le l'utilité peut être
peut être grande et le besoin de
reconnaissance au travers de cette
activité peut être grande donc
par contre effectivement ses biens en
sept catégories là que l'on voit arriver
justement parce que la protection
sociale n'est pas au rendez vous
vis-à-vis de ces personnes je pars
parler des enjeux statistiques
l'excédent parce que de toute façon la
très grande pauvreté est là et les gens
ne s'en sortent pas ne s'en sortent pas
je voulais vraiment revenir sur le sur
vous reparler d'eux comme en sortie
est quelqu'un qui parle
c'est autre chose d'accord
je pensais qu'il y avait une question
derrière pour samy
oui enfin revenir sur cette histoire de
revenus convenables d'existence et dans
la constitution on ne devrait même pas
avoir à batailler depuis tellement
d'années maintenant pour que les
personnes et toutes les personnes à
partir de 18 ans puissent avoir accès à
un revenu convenable d'existence wallace
une discrimination terrible par l'âge
d'imaginer que les 18 26 ans n'ont pas
cette possibilité d'avoir un revenu
convenable d'existence quand en tout cas
on n'a pas une activité
salariée avec d'autres sources de
revenus et pour nous là le fait de
pouvoir permettre cet accès à ce revenu
convenable enfin un revenu qu'on a
d'existence qui serait évidemment à
hauteur de 850 900 euros
permettrait à ces jeunes on va dire de
2,2 de prendre une forme d'autonomie de
pouvoir se projeter de faire de ne plus
dépendre
de la famille et notamment avec le rsa
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui là un jeune
qui est encore chez qui des pas encore
de du foyer familial partir du moment il
va avoir quelques sources de revenus
faire un stage
avoir un petit boulot de quelques
semaines et sert à ce revenu va être
déduits du rsa familiale ce qui est
absolument terrible c'est pour ça qu'on
on parle
d'individualisation c'est pour ça que la
réforme de ce revenu celui de solidarité
active est absolument indispensable
parce qu'aujourd'hui
tant que le revenu est familiale on va
dire pour des jeunes en tout cas qu'ils
dépendent encore de leur famille à 18
ans il n'y a aucune possibilité
d'émancipation et de pouvoir se projeter
se loger se nourrir s'habiller
est toujours dépendre de ses parents
enfin voilà ça c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel donc par rapport à ce revenu
enfin on est aussi dans des questions
d'imprévisibilité mon permanence le rsa
ne permet pas de pouvoir vivre les
mi-temps car monde en tout cas le 10 et
le prouve et le démontre que
l'imprévisibilité dans leur vie fait que
effectivement ça empêche aussi de de se
projeter sur parfois trouver une
activité salariée puisqu'on est en
permanence dans l'urgence les gens sont
en permanence dans l'urgence et ça agit
évidemment l'impact est très très fort
sur la santé sur la santé des des
parents notamment qui voilà donc le on
vous parliez sanctions aussi tout à
l'heure
par rapport au fonctionnement même du
rsa enfin et des droits et devoirs on
parle nous d'inconditionnalité puisque
tant que ses droits et devoirs sont
souvent plus tôt
les administrations les prescripteurs en
fait qui exige effectivement des
personnes
de mené que 2 voilà de rendre compte etc
et les sanctions qui tombent souvent
sont extrêmement difficile pour les gens
puisque ça les plonge dans la grande
pauvreté de fait mais ça ça ça aussi
encourage le non recours nous les quand
on a travaillé sur cette évaluation du
rsa ces derniers mois les gens explique
aussi qu'à un moment donné les gens
baissent les bras et donc non non plus
recours à ce rsa de parler les
contraintes de la vie privée l'intrusion
dans la vie privée etc donc c'est c'est
un système qui n'est pas vertueux enfin
voilà
l'objectif du rsa et de sortir de la
pauvreté ça c'est dans la loi
aujourd'hui avec un rsa on ne sort pas
de la pauvreté c'est pas possible je
voulais aussi
évoqué les aspects de l'emploi etc donc
on a parlé territoire zéro chômeur le
concept et la façon dont s'est imaginé
et finalement nous aussi on dit ne pas
ne faut pas aujourd'hui
le généraliser d'une façon une façon
d'une façon très forte puisqu'il faut
continuer l'expérimentation et continuer
d'évaluer et d'analyser en fait ce qui
se joue dans dans ce dispositif dans
cette expérimentation ce pas un
dispositif mais voilà nous ce qu'on
défend donc arrêter des 47 territoires
zéro chômeur en fête a été a été pensée
effectivement à partir de l'entreprise
solidaire dans laquelle qui existe
toujours un qui s'appelle travailler
apprendre ensemble à noisy-le-grand et
c'est là qu'on se rend compte
effectivement qu'à partir de l'hymne du
moment où les personnes ont un cdi
puisque territoire zéro chômeur dans les
entreprises à but d'emploi les personnes
ont un cdi
on arrive à stabiliser les choses pour
les personnes et l'aspect imprévisible
n'est plus et plus là c'est à dire que
les gens peuvent avec une stabilité
peuvent de nouveau se soigne et peuvent
de nouveau pour certains récupérer leurs
enfants quand ils ont été placés pour
raison de difficultés de logement ou
doux de non logement etc etc donc on
sait que
permettre à des personnes de travailler
notamment à l'expérience qu'on mène donc
avec territoire zéro chômeur redonne
évidemment une
utilité sociale etc etc face et vertueux
quoi voilà donc il faut absolument
penser cette solidarité dans notre
société de faire place à chacun à partir
de kylie et des compétences qu'il a et
donc on revient au jeune
je voulais juste faire remarquer
[Musique]
donc les intentions peuvent être là
au niveau de notamment garantir j'en ai
parlé tout au début
cette histoire de garantir une formation
un accompagnement que l'état puisse
garantir ça pour tous les jeunes de 16 à
18 ans
c'est évidemment ce qu'on souhaite et ce
qui devrait permettre aux jeunes après
de pouvoir s'ancrer dans la vie sociale
dans la vie professionnelle etc mais
aujourd'hui donc toujours les liens
qu'on a donc avec certaines missions
locales ou de certains professionnels
par exemple si on cite les hauts de
france depuis deux ans que ce programme
a été annoncé donc effectivement des
fonds ont été dédiés donc il faut
effectivement des professionnels pour
aller vers on on ne fera rien sans sens
cette façon de travailler qui va être de
rencontrer d'aller vers les personnes
qui sont vraiment invisible et y en a
des milliers des milliers et des
milliers donc comment aller vers ça
c'est la première chose et donc former
les professionnels et là on nous disait
par exemple que dans les hauts de france
il ya aucune formation qui est inclus
dans le programme national des
formations des missions locales qui
vient de sortir pour 2021 aucune
formation n'a été prévu c'est à dire que
les c'est ce qu'on nous a dit hier
comment
les missions locales ont reçu aussi je
peux au moins 2 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir
voilà mais aujourd'hui donc
les choses sont pas sont pas enclenchées
pour qu'on aille jusqu'au bout on va
dire jusqu'au bout de ça et notamment
alors l'autre l'autre chose qui m'a été
pointé très clairement c'est que dans
les hauts de france
par exemple pour accès pour permettre à
des mineurs d'accéder à des programmes
de formation régionaux et bien
aujourd'hui l'axé un programme de
formation régional est interdite aux
mineurs
aujourd'hui ça fait deux ans qu'on a
lancé cette idée effectivement de
pouvoir permettre à des jeunes de 16 à
18 ans d'être formés et c'est alors
qu'il ya obligation notamment pour les
missions locales aussi d'accompagner et
de faire en sorte que le maximum de
jeunes puissent obtenir une formation
ils s'inscrivent dans les programmes
voilà donc on est parfois dans des
voiles ont demandé des choses très
paradoxal et qu'il faut absolument aller
jusqu'au bout en fait d'une mesure comme
celle là ce qui permettrait
effectivement de de permettre à des
jeunes de pas
d'avoir un espoir d'être formés avoir un
espoir d'avoir un métier à condition que
ce soit effectivement un métier et est
une formation qui soit choisie c'est
toujours le même problème de penser à la
place des gens ou de d'imaginer les
choses à la place des personnes donc ça
veut dire nouer des relations de
confiance etc etc ça se décrète pas donc
il faut c'est un rythme c'est un travail
ses habitants et ça je pense dans le
travail social je suis issu du monde du
travail social je peux en parler très
très de façon très à l'aise en fait tant
qu'on donnera pas aux professionnels le
temps pour rencontrer nouer des
relations et véritablement bâtir des
projets
on s'en sortira pas ce sera toujours
très très difficile
voilà j'ai passé
[Musique]
peut-être par rapport à
l'aide alimentaire effectivement j'ai
parlé d'institutionnalisation de l'aide
alimentaire ce que j'ai à td comme les
autres associations on a été invités
depuis un an maintenant par la dgcs
régulièrement pour faire des points sur
où on en est et les urgences absolues et
c'est donc on année on a même nommé je
pense la période convient que étant une
crise humanitaire on est en crise
humanitaire en france aujourd'hui
sauf que penser institutionnalisée
l'aide alimentaire c'est une hérésie
c'est une hérésie ça veut dire qu'on
prend acte définitivement qu'en france
et des millions de gens qui vont qui
meurent de faim ou qui qui sont obligés
de se battre pour pour pour
véritablement nourrir se nourrir ou
nourrir sa famille on parle évidemment
les étudiants etc enfin tous ceux qui
ont perdu tous les petits boulots qui
permettait effectivement de de pouvoir
se nourrir et vivre et payer son loyer
mais mais toutes les toutes les
personnes qui sont effectivement avec
des minima sociaux aujourd'hui et qui
n'ont pas cette chance de d'avoir un
emploi ou un travail il n'ya pas
d'emplois qui sont aujourd'hui
disponibles ça se saurait donc c'est
comment on va repenser tout ça on a un
peu parlé avec territoire zéro chômeur
mais mais mais aujourd'hui en fait
imaginer l'aide alimentaire comme étant
une femme soit est une solution pour
lutter contre la pauvreté c'est une
hérésie voilà donc cesser voilà comment
on va penser plutôt un revenu convenable
d'existence qu'en france on arrivera à
penser à un revenu convenable
d'existence et je pense qu'il ya un
consensus qui est trouvé avec toutes les
avec les associations qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de dire de le crier je sais
plus comment il faut faire parce que on
est en audition en permanence tous les
jours voilà encore la semaine prochaine
quasi tous les ans on peut dire quasi
tous les jours on se relaye on peut pas
notre président ne peut pas être à
toutes les auditions tous les deux jours
et séraphin enfin voilà prenons soyons
dans un courage je sais pas s'il faut du
courage pour sam et
établissons les choses telles qu'elles
doivent l'être pour que des personnes
arrêtent de ne pas vivre de ne pas
réussir à vivre et de pas se loger du
coup sachant qu'il ya pas assez de
logements en france
merci oui vous avez assez peu parlé
finalement de la politique du logement
ça a été dit tout à l'heure il ya eu de
gros effort de fait notamment pour la
mise à l'abri dans le cadre du
confinement je sais pas si en tout cas
l'uefa la loi sru vais juste parler deux
secondes mais la loi sru ne serait-ce
que celle là on a des lois en france fin
on va arrêter de se battre pour des
nouvelles lois
faisons les appliquer appliquons les
faits l'histoire la domiciliation ça
c'est le secours catholique a souvent
parlé la domiciliation mais appliquons
les lois en tant qu'élus et c'est enfin
fait en sorte que les lois soient
appliquées
j'ai on a tout ce qu'il faut en france
on a cette chance là effectivement on a
un système de protection sociale etc et
puis voilà ce sont des choix politiques
enfin il n'y a pas d'autre voie là on
les les constats on les fait on les
refait depuis toujours ce verger pis il
ya des questions des participants
rapidement effectivement d'abord mais
merci quand même de faire cette audition
parce que même si on est content on est
aussi très heureux qu'il y ait des
prises de conscience que manifeste le
les nombreuses auditions
qu'il faut faire quelque chose en ce
moment et ça ça nous semble très positif
et ça veut dire effectivement que vous
pouvez être audacieux dans les
propositions de vous pouvez faire parce
qu'il ya une prise de conscience dans
l'opinion publique en tout cas chez les
décideurs je sais pas mais je crois
aussi qu'il y a vraiment quelque chose à
faire en ce moment donc vous avez cette
opportunité mais aussi peut-être cette
responsabilité
oui oui mais c'est vrai que fin sur on
voit bien que les mesures s'est pas fait
pas toujours consensus mais je crois
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup qui se
disent qu'ils ne peuvent pas ne rien
faire ou faire juste comme avant
et je voudrais insister sur ce que vous
avez dit très justement dire que le fait
que l'on passe aujourd'hui à près de 8
millions de personnes qui font appel à
l'aide alimentaire c'est quand même
l'indicateur majeur de l'échec de lutte
contre la pauvreté en france
donc si on peut à la fois améliorer les
actions du côté alimentaire avec des
actions d'accéder à l'alimentation il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce
domaine mais l'objectif principal c'est
de faire que les gens n'aient plus
besoin de l'alimentaire et ça ça passe
par le rhône il n'y a pas 36 solutions
il faut assurer un revenu digne à chacun
et faire en sorte effectivement soit
qu'ils aient un emploi au maximum y
compris au travers de mécanismes de type
garantie à l'emploi et aussi que pour
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas ou pas encore
qu'ils aient un revenu de remplacement
qui soit suffisant à tout le moins pour
couvrir les besoins essentiels
est ainsi partie prenante de la société
et de façon réelle
alors sur le logement en fait il ya eu
des efforts faits sur l'hébergement
effectivement et ça on le salue
c'est pas tout à fait à 100% vous
évoquez le voeu que dans les mares où
l'on peut rencontrer plus de monde dans
certains territoires mais aussi
cultivant les territoires où beaucoup de
personnes ont été logées ou il y a
plutôt une baisse
bon l'hiver est aussi une période de
mobilisation en général donc c'est pas
qu'aux locaux vides mais malgré tout on
voit qu'il ya de la mobilisation qui a
un vrai effort d'ouverture de classe par
contre sur le jugement on n'y est pas du
tout et le rapport la fondation des
pierres le rappelle
on est encore moins sur les pays donc on
a des engagements mais en fait dans la
réalité il se passe pas grand chose et
donc
voilà et même sur quelque chose qui
paraît très évident comme la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments qui veut un
trait à la fois d'avoir des bâtiments
plus nombreux mieux
sécurisés par rapport au froid plus
écologique et créant de l'emploi même ça
on n'arrive pas à déclencher un vrai
plan à la hauteur des enjeux en tout cas
même si les annonces sont là ils vont
sans doute être encore là aussi avec un
projet de loi sur le climat mais bon il
ya sur le joint et encore énormément à
faire mais sur l'hébergement c'est vrai
que une mobilisation qui globalement
porte ses fruits et qui montrent que
c'est possible aussi d'arriver à cet
objectif politique on pourrait dire de
zéro sdf mais effectivement c'est tout à
fait possible on n'est pas dans des
chiffres qui rendra impossible
on est de l'hébergement d'urgence et pas
du logement qui donne de la perspective
et donc qui permettent de travailler
aussi dans la durée sur d'autres
d'autres sujets
la question c'est quand on va sortir ce
que l'on espère quand même temps de
l'hiver que aussi de cette crise de
toute façon on sait déjà qui a trente
mille places qui sont pas des places
pérennes donc ça veut dire quand même
trente mille personnes sur lesquelles
nous avons quelques mois pour trouver
des solutions et aujourd'hui avec un
parc où vous l'avez rappelé en tout cas
où on n'est quand même pas certain
d'avoir trente mille justement est bel
et bien un logement et que ça pose aussi
dans une politique publique qui se veut
quand même axée sur le logement d'abord
de des efforts qu'on a quand même à
poursuivre pour être sur ses solutions
de logement et non de mise à l'abri
[Musique]